monsieur bella bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
alors pour beaucoup un sentiment anti
français gagnent du terrain dans le
monde musulman mais chez certains
clients historiques de la france comme
l'arabie saoudite
pas d'appel au boycott vous êtes
spécialiste de la question quelle est
votre analyse
bonjour moi je crois que cette campagne
elle a déjà commencé bien avant le
discours du président concernant le
séparatisme on entendu des voix de la
mouvance des frères musulmans
principalement du qatar qui vise
l'économie française et qui vise à
boycotter les produits français et bien
évidemment avec les deux discours du
président là la tension est là elle a
beaucoup élevé et en fait on peut dire
que c'est une campagne qui est menée par
la turquie et le qatar contre l'économie
française je qualifie ce genre d'acte
comme étant du terrorisme économique
c'est à dire c'est une façon pour salir
l'image de la france pour diaboliser des
politiques françaises qui concerne
l'intérieur français donc en fin de
compte c'est une façon d'ingérence par
rapport à tout ce qui est chaud
religieux il politique en france
maintenant effectivement on a un grand
échange commercial entre la france et il
le monde arabe en général c'est un
échange commercial qui dépasse 50
milliards d'euros on a des
investissements qui créent de l'emploi
qui vont avoir des l'homme pas que même
sur certaines économies du monde arabe
en terme de de croissance est également
de création d'emplois surtout par
rapport à une conjoncture économique
exceptionnelle et très très compliqué à
cause du coc vie de 19 et en fin de
compte c'est une campagne qui veut avoir
un impact économique mais son objectif
principal il son objectif caché c'est un
objectif purement politique
un objectif purement politique on se
pose la question de l'implication de la
turquie on a vu
la dernière sortie de ratchet tayyip
erdogan avec des mots très durs envers
le président emmanuel macron quel est le
rôle justement de la turquie dans tout
ça on sait que cet appel de boycott a
été lancée par des pays comme le qatar
le koweït à des pays qui sont très
proches de la turquie tout à fait donc
en fait le dénominateur commun entre le
qatar la turquie et la mouvance des
frères musulmans au coes effectivement
cette question de l'islam politique
parce qu'ils savent maintenant que le
dernier discours de monsieur mc ren vise
effectivement la question de l'islam
politique en france est de mettre en
place des mesures contre l'ingérence de
la turquie dans le champ religieux
français c'est très conne à de multiples
crises avec la turquie on peut parler de
la crise en libye de la crise de grèce
ce qui se passe entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie mais aussi ce que je comprends
pas c'est que la position de certains
pays du golfe notamment le qatar le
qatar est là des investissements en
france qui dépasse 40 milliards d'euros
le qatar profitent des incitations
fiscales et des avantages fiscaux depuis
l'époque sarkozy en france et en
contrepartie on voit qu'il ya un
comportement très agressif un
comportement violent ont vis-à-vis de la
france un comportement qui vise
diaboliser les politiques françaises
alors que tu ce qui se passe quand cerne
la communauté musulmane en france et
concerne en fin de compte des lois
françaises soit en ce qui pensèrent la
laïcité ou bien l'organisation de la vie
politique ou religieuse on va dire en
france maintenant ce qui est clair c'est
que il faut bien évidemment apprendre de
ce genre de crise il faut décider
d'avoir une nouvelle approche au niveau
du moyen orient en termes de relations
internationales et des affaires
étrangères et savoir que celui qui a
beaucoup d'amis n'a pas d'amis il faut
savoir choisir sélectionner les
partenariats stratégiques qui ce qui
réconcilie la partie politique et
économique avec les valeurs et le
comportement français en ce qui concerne
la lutte contre l'islam politique
alors justement c
les appels au boycott risque d'avoir un
préjudice sur le secteur de la grippe
agroalimentaire on sait qu'il ya pas mal
de produits qui ont été retirés
justement des supermarchés match jusqu'à
maintenant pas un mot sur les produits
de luxe ou encore l'armement on sait
qu'il ya énormément de contrat
d'armement entre la france et ces pays
là pourquoi le boycott n'est pas suivie
dans ce sens également effectivement
surtout les pays du golfe ce sont les
des bons clients en termes d'armement
les couettes elle a fait déjà des
contrats d'armement avec la france
depuis deux ans le qatar aussi à acheter
le rafale
ça fait maintenant trois ans au est donc
en fin de compte et c'est vrai que les
produits d'armement sont pas cités mais
ces sites et c'est principalement des
produits d'agro d'agroalimentaire ce qui
montre en fin de compte que déjà
l'impact on va dire de ce boycott en
termes économiques
il est très très limité en terme de
chiffres et le geste et les faits juste
pour avoir en quelque sorte une façon de
salir l'image de la france est de mettre
une pression pour avoir des changements
au niveau politique en france ce qui est
aussi très important c'est que
l'objectif de cette campagne c'était le
fait de la transmettre en interne en
france c'est à dire le fait de
d'influencer l'opinion publique aussi de
l'eau de la communauté musulmane en
france pour qu'elle mette en quelque
sorte un boycott pour que se manifestent
contre les politiques du du président
aux soins en termes de séparatisme bien
de de l'islam politique maintenant je
crois qu'il faut vraiment éclairé cette
question est de savoir est-ce qu'on de
mettre en place en fin de compte un
dispositif concernant les relations de
la france vis-à-vis de certains pays de
du golfe qui ont un comportement
paradoxal notamment le kata et aussi
concernant la position de la de la
turquie parce qu'en fin de compte
l'ingérence de la turquie dans le champ
religieux en france qui était tout à
fait le moteur de toute cette de toute
cette toute cette crise et qui va avoir
certainement des conséquences par la
suite sur les relations entre les deux
pays
merci beaucoup et younes à baltanas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle
économiste et spécialiste du monde arabe